We're getting near the end of
lesson one in this course.
And in a normal course, after finishing
lesson one, you would go on and
watch lesson two.
But we don't have a lesson two.
In fact,
this is the only lesson in the course.
Where you would usually find lessons
you'll instead find a curated library of
research publications,
media articles, original interviews,
and things to help you
develop your understanding of whatever
topics you're most interested in.
In this course, instead of watching
a series of lessons in some sequential
order, you'll instead find your way
through this library however you want.
Choose the topics that are most
interesting to you and
really delve into them.
Read about them.
See if you can find your own sources for
them.
If you have any questions on
what you should go into or
what you should read about.
Ask your mentor,
ask your classmates, ask me, and
we'll help you guide you
through the course library.
But the goal is that your trajectory in
this course is really determined by you.